العدل في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه البرلماني
الليبي يرفض اعاده فتح ملف لوربي مثلا
التفاصيل ومن يسعى الى اعاده فتح هذا
الملف وباي غايه وايضا من هو بعجله مسعود
او سيره خلال الايام الاخيره قضيه ابو
عجيله مسعود المريني وهو احد همم
المسؤولين في جهاز المخابرات الليبي في
النظام السابق قبل عام
10 وهمم بعجيله سعود همم احد الطالعين في
اسقاط طائره لكربي عام
بعد ذلك اغلقت هذه القضيه باتفاق بين
ليبيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه عام
2008 وزاره بعد ان اثير
الجدل حيث اختفى همم
بعجيله المريمه من سجنه الذي يقبع فيه في
طرابلس منذ عام 2000 واحد عشر ما اثار هذه
القضيه لا مجددا والبعض يتهم حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه بانها طالعه في هذا الامر ولكن
حكومه الوحده قد نفذ ذلك من خلال وزاره
العدل التي قالت بان هذه القضيه قد اغلقت
سياسيا وقانويا ولا يمكن اا اثارتها همم
من جديد
ورفضت كل اشكال اثاره هذه القضيه ايضا
مجلس النواب في الشرق الليبي قد السنه قد
وضع قرارا قضى فيه بمحاكمه المتورطين في
اثاره هذه القضيه واتهم من يسيرون همم هذه
القضيه مجددا بالخيانه العظمى وحث على
ضروره ملاحقه المتورطين في القبض على همم
بعجيله مسعود المريني وضروره انهاء ايضا
سجنه بعد ان
من عمليات خطف هي التي ما زالت مستمره ولا
يعرف مكانه حتى الان كلها شكرا جزيلا لك
معاذ الشيخ مراسيلنا متحدثا من العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس